hello I'm Shana Badawi and welcome to
this BBC World News intelligence squared
debate coming to you from the very heart
of Hong Kong and you know what is the
first for intelligence squared we have
an all-female panel so surprise surprise
our topic today has a female related
theme you know everywhere in the world
professional women are really breaking
the barriers there are more female
executives than ever before the number
is rising admittedly from a low base but
it does show that the glass ceiling is
being broken but can a woman enjoy a
glittering and successful career and be
a great mother to well that is our
motion the hand that rocks the cradle'
cannot rock the boardroom and we have a
terrific panel today two speakers
against the motion and two speakers for
the motion and we also have a great
audience sir who also going to be giving
us their points of view and questions so
arguing for the motion Deborah's pas
president of Barnard College in the
United States and Allison Pearson
award-winning British journalist and
writer and against the motion
Helena Morrissey top CEO and wait for
this mother of nine children and also
Chinese billionaire Shang Shin so that
is our panel welcome to you all
so our first speaker for the motion the
hand that rocks the cradle' cannot rock
the boardroom is Deborah spa president
of Barnard College now that's a liberal
arts college affiliated to Columbia
University in the United States she's
written many books but her book wonder
women sex power and perfection it has a
central message that women should stop
trying to be good at everything thanks
for that tip / Deborah and Deborah is a
very vocal proponent of women education
and leadership and previously she was a
professor at Harvard Business School
so Deborah please come to the podium
your time starts now
the hand that rocks the cradle' cannot
rock the boardroom let me repeat the
hand that rocks the cradle'
incontrovertibly cannot rock the
boardroom
this isn't sexism this isn't
conservatism
it's simply math a nursing mother will
spend on average 18 hours a week simply
feeding her newborn then unless she has
full-time help common in some parts of
the world but not most she will spend an
additional 40 hours a week tending to
the household chores that tend to attach
themselves to small helpless creatures
in addition our average woman will
probably spend countless hours taking
care of an older child or two going to
doctors visits clothes shopping
playdates she will probably be spending
additional hours that we won't bother
counting looking after spouse who might
as well be looked after because she can
barely find time to get out of the house
maybe a wonder woman can make the math
work if she's working 33 hours in the
home and maybe even as much as 40 hours
a week if she has a very predictable or
very flexible job and again she is
Wonder Woman but a CEO the chair of a
publicly traded corporation the head
quite frankly of any major enterprise
it's simply not possible or at least
highly highly unlikely now clearly there
are many forces at play here
discrimination sadly is alive and well
but at the end of the day the dominant
reason and in fact I think the scariest
reason why we don't see more mothers
among the ranks of these leadership
positions is that these leadership
positions
are simply not 35 hour a week jobs they
are not 40 hour a week jobs being a CEO
or being in a position where one is able
to rock the boardroom in the vernacular
of this debate is a 50 or a 60 or a 70
hour a week job with in addition
international travel sudden and
unmovable deadlines and that global
plague known as the international
conference call now there are some
logical flaws and what I've just laid
out women can can find or hire somebody
to rock that cradle for them and if they
are willing to hire a cradle rocker then
they can rock the boardroom that cradle
rocker can be a nanny if they have the
means to do so it can be a mother-in-law
if that works for the family it can be
it can be a partner again if that works
for the family but in any case this
cradle rocker that the mother acquires
or hires has to truly be the primary
cradle rocker finally women can also
choose and this is a very legitimate
choice not to have children and to
concentrate instead on their boardroom
activities in all of these cases though
the underlying constraint crucially does
not change if they want to stay in the
boardroom or get to the boardroom
quickly women and men can not at the
same time be rocking the cradle this is
not again a matter of skills or
preferences or biology but rather just
that at the end of the day there simply
are not enough hours in the day bearing
this in mind the sheer mathematical
impossibility of any one man or woman
being able to simultaneously rock the
cradle and the ballroom I asked you
please to join me in supporting the
proposition before you thank you
Debra thanks very much indeed Debra's
father nailing her colours to the mast
in this debate all right against the
motion we now have Helena Morrissey she
is CEO of Newton Investment Management
she's also founder of the 30 percent
Club which aims to get 30% of women in
British boardrooms by the end of next
year but key thing is and we all want to
know how she did it is she is not only a
top CEO she's also the mother of nine
children Helena how do you do it
I am definitely not Wonder Woman but I
think I hope that I am pretty strong
evidence if not incontrovertible proof
that you can rock the cradle and rock
the boardroom although I've never asked
you tried rocking it it's going to be
said but anyway I think if I make might
pick up on one point just before I get
on to my topics that I wanted to discuss
this idea that you have to do everything
all of the time and this idea of the
mathematical impossibility I think that
you're setting our expectations too low
and I have found that a lot of women in
particular restrict themselves by
actually worrying and agonizing and
spending a lot of their hours thinking
about all the things they can't do
whereas actually we are all capable men
and women of doing a whole lot more I
feel I felt a bit disparity when I saw
the title of the debate I have to admit
and the idea of setting of fueling
doubts and the idea of continually
challenging sort of where we've got to
with working mothers and working women
and that you can't try or achieve both
and I would rather that we spent our
energies on how and how we make what
life and work work for parents and
others as well in the modern era what
we've seen of late in particularly in
the UK but in some other parts of the
world because obviously this is a global
issue it's a real energy now around
trying to change the place of work to
encompass other aspects of people's
lives it really works for me because of
Technology I will be the first to admit
that I don't work the longest working
hour in the day I am very disciplined
about when I leave for home obviously
when I'm in Hong Kong that's slightly
difficult but I am very disciplined
about trying to get home to have a
family supper and then as as I need to
my company is owned by an American bank
then I make some time for work later on
in the evening and each time of the day
I am dipping out of
just to work but the 30% club which is
achieving a lot of success in terms of
accelerating the pace of change and of
course my family and it isn't an
either/or it isn't a one or the other
and I'm not prescribing one or the other
for people what I have decided to do is
very much a personal choice I certainly
wouldn't be prescribing necessarily nine
children as a sensible way forward for
everybody and although see me better
afterwards if you run to have any
thoughts on that but you know it can
work it can work I'm happy I feel
fulfilled it is enjoyable I have an
amazing family I have an amazing husband
who does support me and I have an
amazing company who recognizes that my
contribution comes through the bottom
line not am I sitting in one office 24
hours of the day so I would urge you
very passionately that if you don't want
to create a setback for women today if
you don't want to fuel the doubts if you
don't want to have our generation and
I'm 47 very much part of a transition
generation our mothers tend to be at
home our daughters expect to go out to
work we're in that that danger just so
when there isn't a very clear societal
norm and where we have to set an example
that isn't just for our own fulfillment
but is for economic growth is for the
sake of our children and their ambitions
and also is ultimately for other women
who see that things can be done without
making that big choice between family or
work so I would like to encourage you
very firmly to oppose the motion to
encourage young women coming up behind
us to see that you both can rock the
cradle nine times if you really want to
and be a CEO thank you
Helen and Morrissey there thank you very
much indeed with a rallying cry to the
younger generation very brave of you to
admit that you are 47 you don't look a
day over 37 Helena though we go clearly
doing something right okay for the
motion of the hand that I'm not gonna
tell you my age incidentally if you know
what I never mind if anybody asked me
how old I am because I'm quite prepared
to lie but anyway for the motion the
hand that rocks the cradle' cannot rock
the boardroom we have Allison Pearson
she's an award-winning journalist for
Britain's Daily Telegraph newspaper and
her novel I don't know how she does it
was translated into more than 30
languages and sold over 4 million copies
it was also made into a Hollywood film
of the same name starring Sarah Jessica
Parker on it's a heartbreaking story of
a woman who struggles with work and
motherhood and Alison herself does
campaign a great deal for better
paternity rights to help women gain true
equality but clearly you don't think
we've got there yet because you are
arguing for the motion Alison your time
starts now thank you
hello everyone in case you're wondering
I'm still 38 after all these years this
is an amazing time to be a woman exactly
a century ago my grandmother left her
small village school in Wales and was
became a very junior maid in a large
house like Cinderella every morning she
got up and she cleaned the ashes from
every fireplace in that big house she
was 13 years old my daughter her
great-granddaughter is 18 and is
presently applying to some of the best
colleges in America so what an ass am I
doing here today telling you that the
hand that rocks the cradle' cannot rock
the boardroom you know it would be so
lovely to say to all the young women in
the audience if you work incredibly hard
and achieve you can have it all I've
seen too many women run onto the rocks
of stress and unhappiness to tell you
that we have been allowed to do our
fathers and our grandfathers jobs but we
have retained our mothers
responsibilities most of us still live
with men who think that the toilet paper
is restocked by the toilet paper fairy
clean socks and underwear appear
mysteriously in men's drawers children's
dental appointments book themselves the
fridge is stocked by unseen hands and
then your husband asks you darling what
have we got my mother for her birthday
that's the woman who has to remember
everything in addition to the stuff she
carries around in her head from the day
job women carry the puzzle of family
life in our heads we just do I remember
a business trip I went on years ago when
my kids were still very tiny and as I
was leaving the house I handed my
husband a list of all the tasks he would
have to take care of while he was away
and he looked totally bewildered for a
while and then he said but it looks like
a plan for invading a small country and
you know he was right in a way because
every mother in this room every mother
in hongkong every mother in Hampshire
Honolulu Honduras Hyderabad runs a small
country called home she is its health
minister and the Secretary of State for
homework and inche are in charge of
policing
unsuitable boyfriends which is where I
am at the moment no you cannot go out
with a mechanic who has a dragon tattoo
on his nose so we all of us look in the
glossy magazines and we see these
fantastic women who are having it all
you know she's with one hand she's
running her corporation with the other
hand she's rocking the double buggy with
the triplets in it you know she has of
course a perfect adoring husband who is
really really happy about his wife is
working 70 hours a week and is too
exhausted to have sex with him is he
really happy no he's not really happy so
let me tell you those women at boardroom
level are not having it all when I wrote
a novel called I don't know how she does
it
I spoke to hundreds of women high
achieving women who were trying to
juggle their career in their family and
what did they tell me privately they
give you a very different story in
public what did they tell me privately
the
min said that they were failing to meet
their own high standards at work and at
home
they were neglecting their own health
shockingly be amazed how many women will
see to everybody else's health first and
leave their own to the end one banker I
love this said to me that it would be
safer to come out as a cocaine addict in
her firm then as a mother she said at
least they at least they have a program
for drug addicts she said motherhood
motherhood is a lifelong and incurable
condition and so it is so as long as the
women stayed childless and married to
their job their careers prospered once
they had a baby or two and two three is
the real killer that's when you get into
trouble it becomes a different story
96% of female graduates from the top
college in France said that having
children or being of childbearing age
was a huge obstacle to career
progression that women can see on the
other side of that fatal glass ceiling
and they ask themselves why would I want
to do that
do I want to bring life into this world
and not be around to nurture it do I
want to be like the advertising CEO who
reads bedtime stories to her daughter
over Skype women have changed enough for
over the past half century we have done
our best to become men to fit in with a
workplace designed by men for the
convenience of men now work needs to
change to suit women ladies we need full
credit for the remarkable unpaid job of
running that small country called home
and until that glorious day I'm sorry
but the hand that rocks the cradle'
cannot rock the boardroom thank you
thank you very much indeed Addison
crikey for such a cheery personality
you're a bit of a pessimist aren't you
Allison vixen
all right Thank You Allison now we have
against the motion
our speaker is a real rags to riches
story Shang Shin started out working
12-hour shifts in a sweatshop but it's
now one of China's richest women she was
named by Forbes magazine as one of the
world's top self-made billionaire women
she's CEO of Soho China the largest real
estate developer in Beijing and Shin is
also very deeply involved in
philanthropy and trying to alleviate
poverty and Shin I think you've got
something like an impressive 7 million
followers on Weibo which is the Chinese
equivalent of Twitter so at least 7
million now are anxiously waiting to
hear what you're going to say so Shin
please come and take the stage thank you
well ladies and gentlemen I'm a CEO of
Soho China is a public traded company
where the largest real estate developer
in offices in China and I'm under just
as much pressure to perform as any other
CEO and at the same time and the mother
of two very demanding boys and I can say
I'm almost always home for breakfasts
and dinners this is all done not because
I'm a superwoman all this is possible
because I have a tremendously supportive
husband who is here tonight can we give
him a round of applause
and I have the very capable assistants
who run my life by the minutes it may
come with its challenges but I as I
would like to convince you are today
women who are excellent mothers are just
as capable if not better suited better
qualified the man to command the
boardroom physically emotionally and
intellectually physically physically
women are perfectly capable of
leadership the idea that women cannot be
capable business leader is obsolete and
old-fashioned this comes from the old
sinking in hunting and gathering and
agriculture societies it is primitive
and it is absolutely irrelevant in the
current corporate environment
intellectually from an intellectual
standpoint now women in many countries
are getting eco education to men for
Chinese women over 50% of college
graduates are girls now in recent years
we're seeing increasing numbers of women
taking up leadership roles outstanding
leaders like Angela Merkel Hillary
Clinton Marissa Mayer and Indra Nui so
many many more they are clearly
demonstrating their every inch
intellectually equal to their male
counter
hearts emotionally this is probably the
most controversial area for debate many
people would argue women do not have the
emotional toughness to deal with the
corporate environment I can assure you
that emotionally women are natural
naturally resilient and they are able to
adapt to the boardroom environment poor
rooms there's plenty of drama managing
risk managing growth or even managing
politics managing malicious competition
these are the ballroom dynamics that
scared the timid wait but as mothers who
have all been well trained in the boot
camp at home emotionally women are
naturally more resilient than men a man
can be more decisive
while women tend to be more
conscientious and more considerate they
have different strengths in terms of
emotion that's why women roles are so
important I believe that the ideal
scenario is to have both men and women
together side by side
men and women are like the two wings of
a bird and it takes both to fly high now
can the hand that rocks the cradle' also
rock the ballroom in my case the answer
is yes you can do both but the
underlying issue is that you need to
want it you need to have a PhD
what does PhD stands for P stands for
poor H stands for hungry d stands for
determined we have plenty of PhDs in our
ballroom some of you may say if what I
say is true why are there not more women
in the ballroom than men
Oh as many as men it is true that even
though we're seeing a stronger female
presence in the corporate world today
the middlee ballrooms are still largely
controlled by men it only reminds us
that we still have a long way to go a
debate like today is a perfect vehicle
to remind women that person that women
that we possess all of the capabilities
necessary to do both rock the cradle and
the ballroom
I applaud intelligences square to choose
this topic for debate today itself is a
great support to women's advancement in
the society thank you all and vote no
so you've heard the arguments for and
against term and the motion the hand
that rocks the cradle' can not rock the
boardroom so we're gonna hear from our
audience but before I do that let me
share with you what the audience here in
Hong Kong voted on this motion as they
were coming into the hall before they
heard our speakers so this is how you
all voted don't know 19% for the motion
21% and so far against the motion going
with Helena and shin is 60%
so the fourth emotion you've got a real
uphill struggle here haven't you ladies
so it will be very interesting to see
how many of the don't knows the 19% you
have managed to bring to your side and
how many you've been able to capture
from this massive 60 percent so all to
play for
don't don't lose heart all right so
audience let me now ask you to put your
comments and your questions and please
be as brief and to the point as you can
and please wait for the microphone to
come to you so lady there at the back
stand and make your point thank you what
do we do as an audience or as you know
as wives as parents today to change the
role and expectations that we have our
fathers and of mothers such that that
enables us to do better you know with
our lives thank you
next one yeah so you need to want to do
it to make them hungry and determined
what in European are the most effective
mechanisms for raising the expectations
young girls today have of themselves to
do that okay thank you my question is
how do we encourage corporate cultures
to accommodate differences for women in
the workplace and successfully suit
their needs so they can't make it to the
boardroom thank you
hi I have a question for Miss Johnson I
am a young associate at an international
law firm I'm trying to make it at the
same time at the same time I face and
combat the daily questions from my
relatives when are getting married when
you're gonna give birth to a baby so my
question is for mr. Allison does your
overseas experience play any part in
your decision and mentality in life and
career balance thank you thanks very
much indeed okay let's go
so Sheen why don't you ask it answer
that question about the young lady
facing pressures to get married and when
are you gonna get married and have
children that kind of pressure well you
just don't pay attention to the pressure
pressure is always gonna be there is if
it's not this one would be other
pressures right you stay at home they'll
be under pressure so I think you just
need to be remember the PhD you gotta
have a PhD stay hungry stay determined
and actually to the other ladies
questions you know how do you how do you
tell your children you're young girls to
stay hungry and determined there's no
better way than you yourself being the
raw model that is the most effective way
I spend my life surrounded by 2,500
young women and and the problem I see is
not that they're not hungry enough is
that they're too hungry almost the
problem is I think we've actually raised
their expectations almost too high
because when they don't have perfect
lives and perfect jobs they feel like
they've failed so I think we need to
raise them hungry but realistic can I
just pick up the young woman's point
about the pressure to have children a
third of our brightest most gifted young
women will never find a convenient time
to take time out of the office to go off
and perpetuate the human race that is
because the corporate structure is
inimical to people too young women being
able to have children it is hostile we
come back does that mean childless women
do better well of course it means
childless women do better because they
are you know they can de facto act as
their male colleagues that is an amazing
stocking and horrifying statistic Helen
oh she wrote no I did think so
in motion today is the hand the rods
crater cannot rock the boardroom and it
doesn't say whether the hand is male or
female and I and there is this
presumption that's pervading all
throughout this that it actually is all
about women one of the things about the
role model point that's come up in the
questioning and and also about fathers
education I did I remember asking and
realizing you know you think have a
realization that you might have an
impact on young women I remember asking
my middle son I have three sons and six
orders when he's about eight or nine
what he wants to do when he grew up and
he looked at me really puzzled and he
said well I thought I'd say at home my
dad so there are there are other you
know we are setting we are setting this
this carving out okay yeah
shin I mean you're a very rich woman
you're a billionaire
does that help you or say that you can
do both rock the cradle and the
boardroom well I don't think it takes
money to do both it takes determination
it takes hunger I still believe that's
the most important thing that you know I
don't know where the statistic of 1/3
1/4 of the college women decide to not
have children is related to them working
in the corporate environment and the
number might even be higher they decide
to stay at home you just don't know
right it's just a number no it's very
definitely women going into the
workplace and then finding that they
can't have children because there's no
particular point in their career
development when it's it's permissible
or they won't be penalized for going out
it's very very difficult once you stop
to go back in very you said in your
opening statement that that kind of
views a bit old-fashioned that was the
phrase you use there is Allison being
old-fashioned and you know if you think
she is is she being old-fashioned not
only being old-fashioned also is
irrelevant we live in the world with so
much help you know you don't need to
cook today if you don't want to cook you
can order food right there are lots of
ways of living that we does not look
like we're still living in the village
that everything has to be done by one
parent all right Deborah and Allison
because there was that comment about
your view is a bit old-fashioned also
from the floor we had somebody saying
about encouraging a change in corporate
culture corporate culture is changing a
bit too
more flexible isn't I think I think we
tend to lump together all of corporate
if you work in mergers and acquisitions
if you're billing hours you kind of have
to be behind a desk 50 or 60 hours a
week now there may be some hopefully we
can change that and I think this is
where men have to get involved I'm very
encouraged by how many men are in this
audience this is a really good sign we
can start to shift the workplace but I
also think we have to be realistic and
bear in mind we spent millennia with one
organization of society and it worked
Marx was right there was a very good
division of labor one partner went out
and made the money hunted the whatever
and the other partners stayed home and
took care of the children it wasn't fair
but it worked
yeah can I disagree with that Debra it
is true that women you know if you
charge hours you need to think
differently right you need to work
differently but bear in mind how does
the work pattern become like this is
because they were designed by men if
there are more women at the top in law
change it won't be the same we in the
company are our company one public in
2007 it's grown its equity based 160
percent
nobody stays in the office after seven
or eight unless this is like a few you
know you know special moments generally
people go home for dinners it's because
we our companies run by 50% women 50%
men until you have that you will not
change the pattern of work all right
okay let's go to the audience now later
here if you stand please and make your
comments and briefly if you would all of
your audience my question is why do
Helena and John need to do it now why
can't you encourage women back into the
boardroom after they've had their
children
these are talented women that we are
losing women like Helena and John should
be trying to encourage those women back
into the boardroom and it isn't
happening
first of all I don't it's just me but
I'm shocked and devastated to learn the
truth about the toilet paper fairy so
the question is you describe this
amazing sweep of history from your
grandmother thirteen years old going
into service from the Welsh valleys to
your daughter now applying for the best
and greatest schools in the world but
somehow you seem to suggest that the
sweep of history and the social change
that's happened in a three generations
that's allowed women to have the choices
that they have today and created the
chances for some to go all the way to be
CEOs some to do both had suddenly
stopped why oh just a sec we'll come to
that yeah hi I work for an organization
that tracks the women on boards of Hong
Kong companies on the Hang Seng Index
companies and there's good news and
there's bad news the good news is the
numbers are trending in the right
direction the bad news is things are
moving at a glacial pace so why is
changed taking so long
okay thanks all right in to Alison let's
just at that point first of all you
spoke very movingly about your
grandmother and your daughter doing very
well why do you think social change has
just suddenly stopped well I don't I
don't think it has stopped to answer
your question I just think we're we're
part of an experiment I mean we you know
it's not been very long I mean you know
my grandmother got the boat what was it
1928 this is very very early days in
terms of the great role of centuries and
I just want to speak for Deborah and I
here if I may which is that we are not
saying in any way that women aren't
talented or don't deserve every
opportunity that's going we absolutely
do I'm not being pessimistic I'm just
trying to say that there are children
here my daughter doesn't want a role
model my daughter said to me when she
was little why can't the weeks be the
weekends mummy sure the babies can see
the children more you've got children
here you don't just have children and
farm them out to somebody hoping that
they'll turn into well-balanced human
beings I don't think you what about that
point about the good news is at least
looking at these figures in Asia things
are moving in the right direction but at
a glacial speed as so is that
I mean that's a bit encouraging ladies
isn't it well glacial is not an
encouraging word but but I do think we
are moving in the direction it's much
slower than than any of us in this room
would like but it is moving and and I
think the more conversations we have
along the lines the better I think I
completely agree with shins point
getting more women at the top will start
to change the dynamic but of course
we're stuck here because if we're we're
in a you know a cycle unless we get more
women through the middle ranks that's
where we're losing them all right we
won't get to the top let's just that
there was one question from the audience
which said women are actually better
after they are children it juggling
ended up having to work out your
priorities and you know I used to work
sort of 6 a.m. to 9 p.m. and do only the
hours between 6 & 8 & 7 & 9 in terms of
real serious work there was a lot of you
know hang about and chatting and so
forth and you get more focus and just
very quickly how do you outsource what
do you decide to outsource is it you get
the takeaway meals you get the nannies
or I think that's such a wonderful
question because I think so many women
and this goes to I think Helen
distortions point women don't outsource
enough you know we want to make the
perfect meal and plump the perfect
pillows the more you can outsource the
better but with a huge caveat money
helps here let's be honest we are
talking about a rich person's problem
but the one part you can't outsource is
the children and I think one of the one
of the traps we all fall into is we
think that it gets easier as they get
get older it actually gets harder why
and this in response to that question
about the Glacial speed at which things
are moving in the right direction but
very slowly why is the pace so slow do
you think why is it so difficult to get
a change in corporate culture I just
mentioned that we've had a really
exciting breakthrough in the UK in the
last three years so we've had the Nord
Davis review and then the 30 percent
Club started about three years ago and
what we've seen is a real sort of change
in mindset so this is not seen as a
women's issue now it's seen as a
business issue and just give a flavour
in 2012 for example half of the footsy
board appointments went to women or 49%
if I'm going to be caught up on it but
really that's a huge change and I think
there's a realization now that biz
cesare better to have better gender
balance throughout them okay more
questions please from the floor yes
please do stand make your comments some
are partners in a law firm we've got 18
kids between us and I know that all of
us everyday wonder if we're doing the
right thing and I think Helena and chin
have said that they are incontrovertible
proof that you can have it all but I
mean I wonder whether you've been a good
mother or not as something that you
don't know now and this may be a
question that you have to put to your
children so do you ever question your
conviction and wonder if there is a
hidden cost that you're not going to
know until the next generation will have
your voice stretched out on the
psychologists chair in a minute just a
minute
okay and you okay another point from the
floor please yeah please I am NOT a CEO
and I agree with all four of you on your
views they're all very relevant of how
you can do it or why you can't do it but
you haven't really addressed how do you
be a committed mother and be able to
succeed in the workplace and I think the
key here is as Alison said flexible
working and how many of these boardrooms
allow flexible working and what can we
do to change that thank you we had a
very pertinent point there which is
we're all talking about this as though
there was some choice in the matter some
women who were mothers have to work out
of necessity so don't make them feel too
bad about it ladies yeah so what do you
do to try to encourage more flexible
working patterns part-time if necessary
what do I do I've been doing it for 12
years so you work part-time that's how
you know like no I don't work part-time
but I am very flexible because I'm a
writer and I you know if you're an
academic
or whatever it's very very different
from having to get out of the house and
although about you know sort of 22-8 in
my house I always say that if they had
those CCTV cameras my children would be
taken away by the authorities because
it's there's a lot of yelling and
shouting but yeah I think the key to
this is far more flexible working and as
the question said from the audience is
women being allowed to come back you
know having some time out with their
kids and then still not being discarded
not being treated as though they're of
no consequence at all anyone here who's
been a mother for a number of years will
know that going back to the office is a
doddle compared to being at home with
three toddlers basically you know at the
risk of sounding like the academic I am
I mean I think it really is useful to
put this in historical perspective brief
because four years yeah we presumed I
promise we presumed the absent father
was the good father that was the model
the father was absent so we're just
trying to shift the model now and I
think this is part of the change getting
to a point where it where it's normal
for the dad to say I have to leave and
go to the ballet recital
we're not there yet but that's where we
need to start pushing for we had a
question from a lawyer who said can
women have it all and a YouTube channel
mentions not you know perhaps stirring
up problems for the future do your
children think you are good mothers even
though you spend anyone's children think
they're a good mother yeah I'm gonna ask
you to so I know what mine would say
when they're teenagers you will have to
ask them obviously but I do think I mean
when your question did make me feel a
bit sacks it's like you're beating
yourself up and we've got to stop
beating ourselves up I mean am i a good
mother
I hope so but I do the best I can and I
know that if I was at home I'd probably
be a worse mother vows of all time and
you know God we I don't feel guilt free
there are always issues where you think
I wish I could do this which could do
that but the time and the energy that
you're spending worrying about that
instead of actually being there for your
child or being there at work it's just
like a pointless exercise so I just
would implore women to be less critical
of yourself and it's sorry
my answer to you would be different
which would be there comes a point when
you have to listen to your heart
okay children change your heart if you
feel if you get to a point where you
feel that you are not seeing enough of
them I would listen to your heart don't
always just bludgeon on it's hunger
isn't just enough children sometimes
they need to be heard to Deborah do you
all three children think you're a good
mother
it depends what day that you ask but I
will say we we need all of us to stop
being so judgmental
I don't think anyone's figured out what
it takes to be a good mother
Shin do your boys think you're a good
mother I'm pretty sure they do very nice
wait till they're teenagers
yeah you know what I know my children my
15 year old teenager who's away at a
boarding school now cause me or I can
call him nearly every day that's how
close we are
you know what he's away my children you
always think I'm a good mother and I
kiss or something that's international
outsourcing I went I went to a school
event once and it was a horrifying event
because the teacher said and the
children are now going to read out
statements about their mothers for
Mother's Day can you imagine like one of
the worst things in human history so my
son stood up and said my mommy does not
work she's writer which was you know and
then another little boy stood up and
said my mummys favorite things are
shouting chocolate and going out you
know what I'm sure you're all lovely
mothers been highly successful women so
I think that we can now get the result
for the vote on this intelligence
squared debate the motion let me remind
you once more is the hand that rocks the
cradle' cannot rock the boardroom quick
quick quick
I need the result we're all desperate to
find out what it is thank you so much
stressful all right so let me remind you
what the vote was before we heard our
four speakers make their
arguments to you so before you heard
what they had to say
I don't know worth 19 percent of the
audience here in Hong Kong for the
motion was 21% and against the motion
was a massive 60% now this is how you
have decided now the final vote the
don't know is 1% the undecided that's
gone massively down from 19% to 1% so
who managed to sway more voters before
the motion or against this is how the
results stacked up against the motion
48% for the motion 51%
not much in it in the end just 3% so I
don't think there is a commiseration
actually it's well done to both sides
you did very well indeed you managed to
sway quite a lot of people only 3% at
the end of war zone Deborah and I I'm
going to need for Deborah now we want to
say we we're all on the same side you
know yeah sure that's very very true
Allison Pearson they're saying actually
there's a great deal of agreement I
think actually panelists that you
probably all agree with that that we
still need a lot more change than we
have seen I think everybody agrees that
the glass ceiling is being shattered a
bit but it needs to be destroyed
needs to be destroyed thank you very
much indeed to the panel to the audience
here in Hong Kong for this intelligence
squared debate and by the way I should
say is five years of intelligence
squared in Asia so congratulations to
them too from me
Zainab Adama we and everyone here in
Hong Kong goodbye